Just like with the z-test, when the t-statistic is far from 0 in either
direction, in other words, if the sample mean is far from this population mean,
we reject the null. The first thing we're going to do is compare the sample
mean with the population mean. So in this case, t is the sample mean minus the
population mean, mu naught, divided by the standard error. And instead of being
stigma divided by root n, we use the sample standard deviation. Since the
t-statistic depends on so many factors, let's takes some quizzes to make sure
we understand how these factors affect the t-statistic, and therefore, our
statistical decision. The larger or smaller the value of x bar, the stronger
the evidence that the population mean that the sample comes from is greater
than this population mean we're comparing it to. Similarly, the larger or
smaller the value of x bar, the stronger the evidence that the population mean
that x bar comes from is less than this certain value we are comparing it to.
And finally, the further the value of x bar from mu naught in either direction,
the stronger or weaker the evidence that mu is not equal to mu naught.